[Musique]
quoi de plus noble que le bois en france
comme dans la région centre la ressource
en est très abondante avec une forêt
particulièrement développée pour le
chauffage ou la construction ses
débouchés sont multiples et pourtant
d'un bout à l'autre de la chaîne les
dysfonctionnements sont nombreux alors
crise au renouveau qu'est ce qui a
véritablement changé ces dernières
années et que manque t-il à cette
filière pour enfin se trouver un avenir
[Musique]
à le feu de bois son ambiance reposante
et chaleureuse
la bûche qui crépite dans l'âtre ça
c'est pour le joli cliché place à la
high tech piloter du bout des doigts ici
même le poêle à bois est connecté je
peux lui demander plus de température
moins de température sans avoir à
actionner des leviers d'accord il va
m'indiquer aussi à un moment donné
je n'y a plus assez de bois pour obtenir
cette température il semble loin le
temps des cheminées ouverte et des
poêles en fonte pour le bois combustible
l'offre s'est diversifiée et ce marché
regorge de propositions à la fois
esthétique innovante et bon marché
la personne qui fait le choix de se
chauffer au bois voire des avantages
énergétiquement économiquement parlant
aujourd'hui il n'y a rien de comparable
au bois bûche la bûche n'est d'ailleurs
plus la seule forme du bois combustible
ces granulés de sciure compact et ont
eux aussi trouvé leurs adeptes
la douceur de ses trois derniers hivers
et les tarifs du fioul domestique
maintenu artificiellement bas ont limité
son développement le bois reste malgré
tout un combustible très demandé nous
sommes ici en forêt de montrichard en ce
petit matin glace et divers séjours de
réception pour se négocier en bois du
loir-et-cher 43 44 chaque grumes est
minutieusement étudiées mesurer évaluer
son client bien ici se fournir en bois
non pour se chauffer mais pour fabriquer
des douelles destiné aux barriques la
sélection de cette précieuse matière
première c'est du sérieux
donc là on vérifie le vérifie la qualité
notre client regarde s'il n'a pas trop
de défauts et ans par rapport à ça il
dit oui ok je prends je prends pas et
après une mesure sa longueur et nous
mesurons le gars m ce qui va donner
c'est une étape primordiale ce qui va
déterminer un petit peu les rendements
suite dans l'atelier savoir sélectionner
déjà les bois de compte plus de fils
possible et qu'on compte belle nature de
bois des joli grain donc pour nous c'est
très très important au niveau de l'achat
des négociations avec notre fournisseur
c'est déterminant
les forêts de la région centre couvre le
quart de son territoire soit 9 cent
quarante mille hectares constitué très
majoritairement de feu du elles
fournissent des bois de grande qualité
en quantité abondante et pourtant les
marchands de bois peine aujourd'hui à
s'y retrouver
il y a notamment la concurrence avec le
nf l'office national des forêts qui
outre son rôle de sylviculteurs pour les
forêts domaniales et donc public s'est
également mise au négoce nous notre
métier ça le réduit au strict minimum
nous sommes de moins en moins nombreux
ça va poser un problème de transmission
d'entreprise puisque les destructions
d'emplois qui se produisent au sein des
exploitants forestiers non on les
retrouve pas de l'autre côté auprès de
l'ot nf
nous retrouvons notre marchand de voix
quelques kilomètres plus loin dans son
autre activité car jean-louis d'aude est
aussi patron d'une scierie on y découvre
des planches destinés à l'emballage et
des bûches pour le chauffage
[Musique]
le gros problème dans l'activité du bois
de chauffage c'est de l'amener à une un
taux d'humidité inférieur à 23 entre 19
et 23 ou aujourd'hui dans les foyers
fermés quel qu'il soit que ce soit à
travers un insert où que ce soit à
travers les nouveaux poêles à bois
ceci permet d'avoir une occidentaux
cambistes et un bon séchage
c'est l'un des critères majeurs de
qualité que tout bon professionnel du
bois de chauffage se doit de respecter
problème l'essentiel de ce combustible
se négocie hors de tout contrôle 80% du
bois bûche est vendue au noir une
activité difficile à maîtriser donc et
un marché qui du coup peine à trouver sa
rentabilité
ce même voilà on vous voir dans cette
qualité à 65 euros sec devrait être
vendu 80 euros qui aujourd'hui ont
pourtant 80 euros dans des foyers fermés
ou du proche pour vous dire ça reste
encore le le combustible le moins cher
du marché au prix du kilowatt qui va au
fond pour encourager les particuliers à
se tourner vers les professionnels
un label régional a été créée centre
bois bûche c'est son nom mais ce label
sera t-il suffisant pour inverser une
tendance aussi pénalisante
nul ne peut le dire aujourd'hui à côté
des bûchers des granulés on a vu se
développer une autre forme de bois
énergie les plaquettes
il s'agit en fait de résidus de bois
broyé une ressource qui permet tout à la
fois de valoriser des matières perdu et
de fournir en combustible bon marché de
grosses chaudières collectives
cette famille d'agriculteurs céréaliers
a saisi l'opportunité pour diversifier
son activité l'objectif ici c'était de
mutualiser et de le potentiel de
matériel de main d'oeuvre et
d'installations qu'on avait dans
l'exploitation agricole
ce hangar il sert à mettre du blé l'été
et du bois l'hiver donc voilà il ya une
vraie mutualisation ce qui nous a permis
de démarrer mais pour aider à garantir
cette qualité on a été aidé par la
région et par l'état à investir dans les
deux éléments qui permettent de garantir
la qualité c'est à dire le crible qui
nous permet de garantir la grosseur des
plaquettes et puis un pont bascule qui
permet de quantifier la quantité qui est
livrée chez vos clients
l'activité est même aujourd'hui devenue
rentable elle s'inscrit totalement dans
une économie de proximité
notre objectif c'est une collecte locale
dans un rayon d'environ 10 km et puis
une une clientèle de chaufferie dans un
rayon de 40 50 km exceptionnellement mai
mais voilà
c'est au tour du fils aujourd'hui de
livrer la précieuse cargaison
direction les tissandier un centre d
aide par le travail
installé à loches en indre et loire la
chaudière à plaquettes a été installé il
y a quatre ans en lieu et place d'une
bonne vieille chaudière à mazout
depuis la facture de chauffage de cet
établissement a sérieusement fondu on
utilisait sur nos deux mille mètres
carrés de bâtiments chauffés
trente mille litres de fioul aujourd'hui
le coût énergétique on va dire sur un
coup fioul ordinaire
on est à 50 % d'économies le choix de ce
type de chaudière n'est en rien le fruit
du hasard écologiques économiques et
éthiques
il s'inscrit dans un projet de
territoire plus globale c'était là la
volonté pour nous d'accompagner une
filière émergente une filière économique
qu'ils valorisent nos produits locaux
qui valorise notre forêt voilà le main
le massif forestier qu'on peut avoir
et puis des acteurs qui avaient envie de
s'investir sur les problématiques
environnementales
voilà c'est du gagnant gagnant pour
l'ensemble du territoire et de ses
acteurs ça crée de la valeur ajoutée ça
crée de l'emploi
ça crée de l'activité et tout le monde
il prend sa part que ce soit les
collectivités et les acteurs privés
un choix vertueux donc
reste que pour se développer ces
nouveaux modèles ne doivent pas
seulement être aidés financièrement
éclairé conseiller guider les
particuliers comme les collectivités
c'est le rôle d'organisme comme l'ademe
ou encore les agences locales de
l'énergie on apporter un conseil à la
fois gratuit et indépendant aux
collectivités aux porteurs de projets
plus largement sur l'opportunité de ces
projets bois aussi sur l'animation de la
filière bois dans le département
et on accompagne ses porteurs de projets
du tout début du projet jusqu'à la fin
qu même un peu au-delà à travers des
visites qu'on peut organiser sur les sur
les sites en fonctionnement
[Musique]
fournir un combustible moderne et
performant n'est pas le seul débouché du
bois c'est aussi un formidable matériaux
de construction dont s'empare désormais
très largement le secteur du bâtiment
nous sommes ici chez ohb et m l'un des
très gros constructeurs de la région
ici on préconstruits des panneaux entier
dans l'atelier même là tous qualité
c'est construire dans une usine à l'abri
dans des conditions idéales des parties
de bâtiments qui seront assemblés sur
site dans un temps record
on sait ici spécialisée dans les bureaux
les locaux collectifs ou les collèges
clés en main il est même question dans
un avenir très proche de construire des
bâtiments de 10 15 et même 20 étages
preuve que le secteur du bois
construction a atteint désormais sa
pleine maturité
[Musique]
retour en forêt mais nous sommes cette
fois ci dans une forêt privée au coeur
de la sologne
le propriétaire de ces parcelles n'est
pas sylviculteurs de métier il se fait
donc aidé par un technicien pour gérer
ses 80 hectares
[Musique]
ils soumettent aujourd'hui à ce
représentant du centre régional de la
propriété forestière ce qu'on appelle un
plan simple de gestion
un document obligatoire pour les
parcelles de plus de 25 hectares et qui
permet de se projeter sur une période de
10 à 20 ans après contrôle
c'est lui qui validera le plan je
vérifie si les interventions prévues
dans ce document sont cohérentes avec le
type de bois qui est sur le terrain et
les objectifs qui sont indiqués par le
propriétaire est assigné à la pro à la
propriété ça c'est un taillis qui était
prévu en coupe dans le projet sans
précédent et qui a été réalisée au quai
franklin maintenant on va laisser la
parcelle telquel 28 va revenir pour les
propriétaires ce contrôle n'est le plus
souvent pas perçue comme une contrainte
mais plutôt comme une aide étant donné
que j'étais pas du tout de la profession
ça m'a permis d'apprendre des tas de
choses de savoir le pourquoi des
commandes des recommandations et pour
finir c'est vraiment une aide parce qu
on a un plan à suivre et ça nous permet
aussi de voir si la coopérative fait
bien son travail
[Musique]
des propriétés forestières morcelé des
unités de fabrication souvent trop
petites et donc trop cher pour prétendre
faire face à la concurrence
le potentiel régional reste encore
malheureusement très sous-exploité il ya
un million d'hectares en région centre
ce qui est très présente 120 millions de
tonnes de bois sur pied et on utilise
moins de 3 % de ce qui est sur pied
c'est effectivement paradoxal parce que
mon le la construction en france
utilisent actuellement trop de bois
importés notamment des avec finnforest
des bois qui viennent de finlande qui la
plus grosse coopérative mondiale
donc c'est la mauvaise organisation de
la filière et le fait qu'ils aient
surtout beaucoup de petits producteurs
qui fait que le bois français n'est pas
assez utilisé pour résister à
l'importation de bois étrangers la
filière doit impérativement se
structurer s'organiser c'est ce qu'elle
a timidement commencé à faire le chemin
sera long
comme la lente croissance des arbres
mais l'enjeu est important dans la
région centre val de loire le bo a fait
vivre 4000 entreprises et représente 25
mille emplois presque autant que
l'automobile
[Musique]